donc on va passer à l'hyper viau et
j'accueille estelle halliday madame s
estelle monde
on est très ferme les frontières de vous
avoir en plus moi j ai tapé une tâche à
cette semaine à la radio à il était une
bonne maman très bien j'ai l'impression
d'être en famille ben alors regardez
bien autres estelle et moi ya un point
commun
mes yeux faut chercher un faux faut bien
chercher il ya un point commun entre
estelle halliday et moi non je ne trouve
pas nous sommes tous les deux de seine
maritime
ah oui estelle et de tôtes voilà et moi
je suis nue a donc voilà on est normand
je sais que si ça pour la rassurer
jamais à l'aise il ya une autre façon de
mettre restait là l'idée à l'aise c'est
de vous dire ce qui est vrai qu'un
sondage l'a classé parmi les trois plus
belle femme de france avec catherine
deneuve et isabelle adjani
vous avez réussi
josé garcia est arrivé à passer de la
télé au cinéma avec un certain succès et
vous êtes arrivé à passer du mannequinat
à la télé avec aussi beaucoup de succès
donc c'est plutôt bien
votre mariage est réussi je m'entraîne à
ce qu'on peut vous dire
alors on vous invite à ce que vous êtes
un couple heureux et vous savez que
demain enfin pendant l'émission ça on va
passer au printemps on va être le 21
mars
donc voilà on voulait célébrer l'amour
c'est surtout qu'on voudrait foutent la
merde donc trouvé bon alors vous êtes né
à tout comme le disait à danser entre
rouen et d'y être
voilà vous faire un plan je connais très
bien et c'est marie qui très bien votre
père qui avait là évidemment vous
mitrailler sans cesse en disant vous
alliez être un top model et quand vous
avez été top model il a dit j'ai
toujours su que tu allais faire ce
métier là jamais dit ah bon vous avez
une enfance assez normal finalement que
maintenant vous fréquentez les grands de
ce monde mais je lisais dans un magazine
que quand vous aviez saison avec votre
petite amie de l'époque parce que on
nous avait quand même eu des petits amis
avant david normal alors mariani donc à
l'époque avec sa petite amie dont je ne
citerai pas le prénom parce que comme
vous avez pu le remarquer on est très
très discret dans cette émission vous
j'ai dit que je crois que ce soit avec
son contrat j'ai des photos avec ce
petit ami vous vendiez des habits des
fripes sur les sur les marchés de c'est
vrai dans les banlieues ouvrières de
ronde mais c'est vrai oui donc c'est
vrai c'est une petite expérience que
j'ai fait c'était sympathique déjà dans
les vêtements finalement elle partisans
les vêtements alors vos parents étaient
été assez d'accord que vous fréquentiez
ce garçon à condition que passer le bac
avant un certain mais finalement le vrai
danger ou à un autre les parents étaient
d'accord que présente le garçon à la
condition qu'elle passe bien son baquet
ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs et à
condition qu'elle habite au dessus du
magasin avec le garçon c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient de la région je savais pas ça
moi je suis désolé j'ai appelé à rouen
j'ai tout le monde l'a raconté sa non
tout ce que je dis c'est je vais lui
dans les magazines c'est évidemment pas
il va beaucoup chez le dentiste regarder
ses dents ah bon mais ça c'est vrai que
vous habitiez au dessus du salon de
coiffure et alors là on en arrive à un
point important c'est comment vous êtes
rentré dans la photo c'est dire qu'un
jour vous rencontrez boulevard
sébastopol quelqu'un qui veut un journal
simple et photos revues c'est ça un âge
et il vous dit je veux faire des photos
avec vous et là je vais vous prendre
dans mon agence dans votre agence ni en
agence et j'ai commencé avec châteauroux
oui mais non parce qu'en fait la preuve
hier fois j'avais 17 ans quand je les ai
rencontrés et c'est là où ma mère m'a
dit non c'est pas son bac et après tu
feras ce que tu veux parti aux états
unis enfin c'est pas tout raconter mais
c'est aux états unis c'est vrai que ça a
été très très vite
oui en trois mois je travaillais pour le
elle et ça a commencé en février est
déjà en juillet j'avais une première
couverture de elle donc c'est très très
rapide dans ce métier là c'est vrai que
ça se passe pas toujours comment l'art
et donc vous réussissez aux états unis
et puis un jour on vous invite de
fonctionner mais je me voyais bien un
jour ici est-ce qu'on va un jour mou y
réussissent et une ravine aux mondiaux
aux états unis et ingénierie d'avant
gens racontent pas la question la loi
n'est ce pas stationnement la ville dans
une émission de tourner invités stella
lys d'émissions de télé parce que tu
veux encore y aller paquin et donc
lefébure c'est ça ça nous fait bien et
maintenant je demande réalisateur serge
khalfon de nous montrer ce qu'on a vu
dans cette émission de télé débattez une
première année en cours pour la suite si
tu dois avoir des enfants
je suis très content avec ce que je fais
je suis toujours en studio je fais
beaucoup de musique mais c'est toujours
ce que j'ai adoré faire possible de
fonder une famille éventuellement plus
tard oui mais c'est compatible
je pense au fait quand même bien placé
pour le savoir
mais pour l'instant c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment le but je pense que
profond des familles il faut d'abord
être faut d'abord avoir un métier je
pense que pour l'instant je suis juste
entre la transition de temps avoir un et
c'est pas tout et tout n'est pas acquis
encore donc il faut attendre un petit
peu je pense
voilà ici
j'ai bien étudié votre dossier je
n'avais pas vous aviez été avec patrick
sabatier ça et donc ses dents les uns et
les autres restaient là l'idée rencontre
patrick c est là inédit rennes la télé
voilà c'est ça l'histoire donc pour
rencontrer david alors c'était vous vous
dites vous qu'il avait déclaré volée
tout mon premier baiser je les données à
l'âge de 12 ans chapelet stéphane il
avait les yeux bleus les cheveux blonds
ensuite j'ai eu quelques petits amis
mais j'ai jamais papillonner mais je
rêvais du grand amour pour ça que vous
êtes là ce soir à cause du printemps
pourri la vie à l'école j'ai rencontré
david
non mais c'est beau match un vrai coup
de foudre ça m'est arrivé aussi quand
j'ai rencontré david j'ai senti qu'il
pourrait devenir mon mari c'est fou tout
de suite malgré la chanson non c'est
vrai tout de suite vous tout de suite
oui c'est évident les escaliers ça a été
le plus bas les beatniks c'est vous
fasciner passage aux est assis mais moi
je trouve ça jamais arrivé
six 6 mois les femmes elle a su tout de
suite bout mais la venue sur moi y'a
forcément là qu'elle est venue sur noye
il a su tout de suite
non mais c'est ça alors que les filles
ont une espèce de davantage en nous
c'est qu'elles savent tout de suite quel
est le mec elles vont craquer et vous
princesse un mois aussi tout de suite ça
ça m'arrive souvent tout de suite
voilà la gauche mais l'homme reste
princess erika n'est pas en france
évidemment c cédille passe à la télé mon
mari aurait gagné à me battre donc quand
vous l'avez rencontré vous aviez le trac
il vous dit bonjour vous ne répondez pas
donc il a crié vous le ce biais
et puis après 8 c'est tout mais c'est
hallucinant il va finir concierge
j'ai 29 ans serge est un jour de votre
ami but de votre agence invite à dîner
et là c'est carré alors vous pouvez pas
lui parler toujours à david on peut pas
lui parler mais regardez vous rougissez
et voilà et là bourgi s'est pas du tout
par un choix on voit bien la différence
on va bien alors c'est l'été platonique
pendant huit mois 1
et puis un soir c'est d'ailleurs après
il ya un sorte de folie est l étalon mal
à travailler toute la journée est elle
est fatiguée dans une chambre d'hôtel
raconte entend ardisson est alors la vie
de l'appel de paris arrêt du mexique
j'avais dit pas le mettre à côté de ça
c'est donc ils appellent ils vous
appellent david de paris et vous fait
rire mais attendait toujours comme ça
que ça marche il vous ferrez et vous a
fait rire comment que je sache
moi je le fais alors dit que sinon je
veux dire il est super équipe et tu peux
y aller sinon j'ai quand on prépare ses
interviews soi même on est mieux les
informer c'est pour ça non mais vous a
fait rire en fait un endroit content
comment ils cassent et les jouets que
johnny hallyday lui offrait non mais
c'est ça oui c'est ça en partie quand
même parce que c'est quoi un an plus
tard alors à peine un an plus tard bah
non plus tard serge ce matin devant la
petite mairie de freineuse il valait
mieux avoir un escabeau pour voir voir
arriver par exemple
sylvie barre quand une maman tous avoué
heureuse johnny hallyday un papa
accompagné d'une ravissante brune est en
train les jeunes mariés à leur sortie de
la mairie
et vous ça vient d'épouser une pile
périble
estelle une normande de 23 ans top
modèle s'appelle famille marié va
officier
souvenirs souvenirs c'était le 12 avril
65 les yéyés triompher johnny et sylvie
étaient les idoles des jeunes les
journalistes n'étant pas admis à
l'intérieur des églises on pourrait
imaginer que les choses se sont passées
ainsi
je suis au top 5 ans tuée top model
alors j'avais pas de me dire isner
moi je sais on a parlé dans les loges
est elle n'a dit a pas de problème aucun
problème à cause des trois c'est à cause
de la règle des trois c 3 ses
communications confiance alors moi ce
que les jeunes étaient là je connaissais
la règle des 4 c et communication
confiance complicité après un cocu qui
vient fermer des classes et c'est pas
pareil
bon maintenant on fait de la télé donc
avec nos amis jérôme revon et stéphane
gâteau donc un samedi soir chez estelle
se passe bien non très bien vous avez
fait combien la dernière fois 26 c'est
bien on applaudit la tournée vans en
californie
la part de marché s'est bien dans les
combien elle si ça peut monter à 34 ah
bon parce qu'à moins de 26 morts
bon avant de passer à la suite oui qu'on
regarde un extrait donc de samedi soir
chez estelle tout d'abord bon vieux
super tant qu'ancienne championne de
natation synchronisée
je recherche a donné des cours de danse
aquatique genève norvégien et ses doigts
que c'était si désireux de modeler leur
corps au fil des ans
je vous attends des jabots blood in et
robuste st berne vue de bien en temps de
situer bras avec une énorme disparité
m'intéresse aussi
c'est vraiment à paris qu'à aller
elle est vachement plus vachement plus
drôle qu'avant roumanoff à tous les gars
donc céder il faut lire une parodie des
petites annonces d'elie semoun et vous
c'est courageux 12 ans les dire comme ça
c'était un cadeau une surprise c'est le
juge
non j'ai joué le jeu c'est dans
l'émission justement c'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire d'avoir des petites des
petites choses comme ça un peu
différente ce gros les autres registres
variés de ces divertissements type appel
bon donc il faut dire que la prochaine
émission et le 14 avril c'est ça 17
avril vous savez quand c'est vous vous
émission sur france 2 oui assez bien
mais c'est en fait en fait mousser le 3
voilà mousser le 3 avril je sais cette
fois bon alors en ce moment où tout le
monde parle de vous pour cette histoire
d'internet l'a eu
donc je sais pas raconter la sphère
comment comment vous l'avez vécu comment
je vais pas là elle a raconté
non simplement c'est vrai que il ya deux
trois petits points à mettre au clair
c'est que ces photos ont été été d'abord
des photos personnelles
quand vous avez comme un volet j'avais
17 ans enfin bon c'était vraiment c'est
pas du tout au tout de même les photos
sur la plage le genre en string ou alors
sans l'eau passait des choses j'ai
personnel c'est oui en plus c'est
vraiment utiliser la gêne donc ce
n'était pas les photos à but
professionnel on me les a volés et
ensuite elle les a volés un proche en
plus à la voiture a pas de présomption
du pad prénom nom ne vous dit pas c'est
si vous vouliez mais c'est donc après
elles ont été vendus un magazine que
j'ai attaqué forcément un deuxième
magasin que j'ai encore attaqué ensuite
on les a vues sur internet vous avez
demandé une amende parce que d'abord me
l'avait demandé au type qui à ce serveur
internet autour de données non du type
qui vous a qui avait mis ses photos sur
internet
et lui n'a pas voulu me donner donc il
est resté le seul responsable et vous
l'avez attaqué et je n'hésite pas la
main morte
vous n'êtes pas mais c'est pas moi qui
demande ça ce sont les tribunaux
heureusement voulait verser parce que ça
alors si vous n'aviez pas fait je
voudrais demander de le faire ce soir
revoir ses quatre cent mille francs bull
est versée à une association pris
ensemble voilà si vous avez des photos
des stèles mettez les sur internet c'est
pour l'enfance mal parce que je voulais
dire moi je propose pour qu'elles soient
tranquilles voulait se déshabille ici j
frais chez vous la cassette à et tu vois
on en parle bon ben écoutez merci
maintenant on va passer à la suite des
événements